i mean i'm a radical empiricist which
i'm i'm very strong with with that like
that's what
you know so you know science isn't about
ultimately being
a materialist it's like it's about being
an empiricist in my view
and so for example i'm very fascinated
by the so-called psi phenomenon
you know like stuff that people just
kind of reject out of hand um
you know i kind of orient towards that
stuff with with an idea of um
you know hey look you know what we
consider like anything exist is natural
and so but the boundary of what what
what we observe in nature
like what we recognize is in nature
moves like
what we do today and what we know today
would only be described as magic 500
years ago or even 100 years ago some of
it so
there will surely be things that like
you explain these phenomena
that just sound like completely they're
supernatural now
where there may be for some of it like
some of it might turn out to be a
complete bunk and some of it might
turn out to be um it's just another
layer of
nature whether we're talking about
multiple dimensions that were invoked or
something
we have don't even have the language
towards and what you're saying about the
moving together the model
and the real thing of conscious like i'm
very sympathetic to that so that's that
part of like
on the arm share side where i i want to
be clear i can't say this as a scientist
but just terms of speculating
i i find myself attracted to these um
more of the the sort of the the pan
psychism ideas and that
kind of makes sense to me i don't know
if that's what you meant there but it
seemed like related the sense that
ultimately if
if if you were completely modeling like
it's like if you completely modeling
unless you dismiss like the the idea
that there is a phenomenal consciousness
which i think is hard given that we all
i seem like i have one that's really all
i i know but
if that's so compelling i can't just
dismiss that like if you're
if if you take that as a given then the
only way for the model
and the and the real thing to merge is
if
there is something baked into
the nature of reality you know sort of
like in the history of like there are
certain just like fundamental forces or
fundamental like and that and that's
been useful for us and sometimes we find
out that that's pointing towards
something else or sometimes it's still
a seems like it's a fundamental and
sometimes it's a placeholder for someone
to figure out but there's something like
this is just a given
you know this is just you know and and
sometimes something like gravity seems
like a very good place holder and then
there's something better that comes to
replace it right
so so you know i kind of think about
like consciousness and i didn't
i kind of had this inclination before i
knew there was a term for it um
resilient monetism the idea that which
is a
a form of pain again i'm not i'm an
armchair philosopher yeah
not a very good one broadly pansexism by
the way is the
idea that sort of consciousness
permeates all matter in
or it's a it's a fundamental part of
physics of the universe kind of thing
so right there's and there's a lot of
different flavors of it as
as you're as you're alluding to and
something that struck me as like
consistent with some just
you know inclinations of mine just total
speculation
is is this idea of um
everything we know in science and with
most of the stuff we think of physics
you know
really describes it's all interactions
it's not the thing itself like there's a
there
there is something to this
and this sounds very new agey which is
why it's it's very difficult and i have
a high [ __ ] like meter and
everything but like in
is-ness i mean you think about like
huxley aldous huxley with his
mescaline experience and doors of
procession like there's an is-ness
there in alan watson like there is a
a nature of being again very new agey
sounding but maybe there is something to
in and when we say consciousness we
think of like this human experience but
maybe that's just
that's so processed and so
that's so far so it's so derivative of
this kind of basic thing
that we wouldn't even recognize the
basic thing but the basic thing might
just be
this is not about the interaction
between particles this is what it is
like to exist as a particle and maybe
it's not even particles maybe it's
like space-time itself i mean again
totally in the speculation
and something very space-time so it's
funny because we don't have this
neither the science nor the proper
language to talk about it
all we have is kind of uh little
intuitions about
there might be something in that
direction of the darkness
right to pursue and that that in that
sense i find pan psychism uh
interesting in that like it does feel
like there's
something fundamental here that
consciousness is it's not just like
okay so the flip side consciousness
could be just a very
basic and trivial symptom
like like a little hack of nature that's
useful
uh for like survival of an organism
it's not something fundamental it's it's
just
this very basic boring
chemical thing that somehow has
convinced us humans because we're very
human-centric we're very self-centric
that this is somehow really important
but it's actually
pretty obvious but or it could be
something really fundamental to the
nature of the universe so
both of those are to me pretty
compelling and i think eventually
scientifically testable
it is so frustrating that it's hard to
design a scientific experiment currently
but i think it's that's how noble prizes
are won
nobody did it right right until they do
it
and the reason i lean towards and again
armchair speaking if i had to bet
like a thousand dollars on which one of
these ultimately
i would i would head i would lean
towards i'd put my bets on
on something like pan psychism rather
than the
the emergence of phenomenal con
consciousness through complexity or
computational complexity because
although certainly what if there is some
underlying
fundamental consciousness it's clearly
being processed
in in you know in this way through
computation
um in terms of resulting in our
experience and the experience presumably
of other animals but the reason i would
blend on
pant psychism is to me occam's razor
it just in terms of truly the hard
problem like this at some point you have
an inside looking out
and even looking refers to vision and it
doesn't that's just an example but just
there's an inside experiencing something
at some point of complexity all of a
sudden
you know you start from this objective
universe and all we know about is
interactions between things and things
happen
and at this certain level of complexity
magically there's an inside
that to me doesn't pass occam's razor as
easily as
maybe there is a fundamental property of
the universe
of you know there's both subjective and
objective there's both
interactions amongst things and there is
the thing itself yes but yeah
so i i'm of two minds i agree with you
totally on
half my mind and the other half as i've
seen looking at
cellular automata a lot which is
complete
it sure does seem that we don't
understand anything about complexity
like the emergence
the just the property in fact that could
be
a fundamental property of reality is
something within the emergence
from simple things interacting somehow
miraculous things happen
and like that i don't understand that
that could be
that could be fundamental that like
something about
the uh layers of abstraction
like layers of reality like really small
things interacting
and then on another layer emerges
actual complicated behavior even the
underlying thing is super simple
like that process we don't really don't
understand either and that could be
bigger than any of the things we're
talking about
that that's the the basic force behind
everything that's happening in the
universe
is from simple things complex
phenomena can happen and the thing that
gives me
pause is is that i'm concerned about
a threshold there like how is it likely
that now there may be and there may be
some
qualitative shift that in the realm of
like we don't even
we don't even understand complexity yet
like you're saying like so maybe there
is
but i do think like if it if it is a
result of the complexity well
you know just having helium versus
hydrogen is a form of complexity
having the existence of stars versus
clouds of gas is a complexity the
the entire universe has been this
increasing complexity
and so that kind of brings me back to
than the other of like okay if there's
if it's about complexity then we should
then it exists
at a certain level in these simple
systems like a star
or or uh you know they all have more
complexes
and that's right but we humans uh the
qualitative shift
we might have evolved to appreciate
certain kinds of thresholds
right yeah i do think it's likely that
this idea that
whether or not there's an inner
experience which is phenomenal it's the
hard problem
that acting like an agent
like having an algorithm that basically
like operates as if there is an agent
that's clearly a thing that i think has
worked
and that there is a whole lot to figure
out there that
that um and i think psychedelics will be
extremely
helpful in figuring more out about that
because they do seem to a lot of times
eliminate that
or whatever radically shift that sense
of of self
you